haley is in denver our first call this
hour hi haley how are you
doing good thank you
um my husband and i are currently on
baby step number two
um our annual income is about 115 000
per year and we have about 75 000 left
in debt to pay off
so i'm thinking that we can be
completely debt free within the next 24
months
amen um and my question is
where do we prioritize family planning
into the baby steps if we're facing an
untraditional path to start our family
through surrogacy or adoption
uh well there's not a baby in the baby
steps um
you have babies when you're ready to
have babies uh but you throw a curve in
there when you say there's a different
kind of a cost here
okay and so um
you know i i think uh and i guess the
other possible
uh question that comes up that's similar
you're not asking that question but the
similar is an in vitro
uh you know when do we do that and i'm
you know i'm 36 and i i
you know i don't want to wait two more
years and that kind of stuff i get that
question over the years a lot
that's in the it's in the same bucket of
questions
um and so uh i i think if you're going
to do surrogacy
or adoption you would do the uh
you would learn so much about these two
things that you would find that there's
a
vast spectrum
that people pay for these things
thousand to a hundred thousand spectrum
yeah we're seeing about 45 to 60
000 depending on which route we take
and if it's in the united states or
international
and my husband is 35 so age is something
that we're definitely
thinking about yeah i think you've got
more research to do
okay we've worked with many many many
families
that have done adoptions for half
of your low number or less and so
i think you're getting a the bentley
pitch rather than the chevrolet pitch on
the adoption process so
um no it does not it doesn't no it does
not cost that much
and so um i i think you've got so you
know
here's the thing when i when i the more
information i gather and the more
options i
have the more power i have in making a
decision and i
i don't think you have enough options
yet as a matter of fact i'm sure you
don't because the prices you're quoting
me are ridiculous
well that's mainly for our
first choice which would be surrogacy so
that we could have a biological child
the adoption would be
secondary okay which we know we can do
cheaper okay
all right and i i you know obviously
there's a lot of ways to compensate a
surrogate
and a lot of price ranges on that as
well so
it's such a personal thing and such an
intimate
thing that it's very hard for somebody
on the radio like me to speak into it
and
and not sound callous or not sound like
i don't care about it i do care about it
it it's just you have got you do not
want to get into these situations
and um and
and look back later and and wow
that uh
it's so emotional it can cloud you from
treating it like a business transaction
as much as you should i want it to be
emotional i want it to be intimate i
want it to matter
but i also want you to use wisdom in the
process does that make sense
yeah yeah so um i'm not trying to be
unfeeling in other words but
uh but but so anyway
uh i can tell you in our life me and my
wife
when we were walking down some of these
steps
we put an end a a line we wouldn't cross
because we knew that once we our hearts
got into this deal
and once there are people around you
always saying well there's another
option there's another option there's
another option that suddenly you wake up
and you're you're you're so far over
your head or you're so far underwater
it's just the whole thing what was going
to be this joyous precious moment
gets really really cloudy what's the uh
75 000 in debt
oh my gosh everything
um we have how much of it how much of
its cars
um about 25 000
but last july it was 90. we
sold well we've surrendered two vehicles
and then we're paying off the deficits
on it but we have two cash cars now
oh okay okay we have two beaters right
now
okay all right so the 25 is the deficits
yeah correct yes and then the rest is
some debt
to um i have a loan with my parents
um and then credit cards just
furniture how much do you owe your
payments what's that
about 20 000 okay
all right i you know i i might
i might consider uh making that a pause
point
in the rest of the clean up the rest of
that snowball because you do want the
cash to be freed up to be able to do
these other things
so i want you working your debt snowball
i want you pushing through the majority
of it but
that 20 i might ask for a moratorium on
that until after the baby
and say mom and dad i'm not going to pay
anything on this because we're going to
get you a grandkid
oh that's a good yeah blackmail and uh
but yeah or i mean negotiate that with
him talk to him about it and and so
uh you know that's a different kind of
debt that you could get
uh you know no payments and no interest
while
you work through this other thing and
then come back to it after a baby
and get it done that would be fine but
um
the question is not really when to have
babies the questions were to stick a 60
000 or 40 000 or 25 000
expense in the middle of your debt
snowball and it's an expense that is
very
intimate very emotional and um
and worth every penny yeah i would
strongly recommend going to a
counselor that you recommend or a pastor
this is one of those moments where your
pictures and words get screwed up right
we think in
in pictures but we speak in words and
we're both saying baby and we're both
saying
kid and we're both saying pay off the
debt and
that's when one of you has one picture
the other's got another one so just
being able to have a
third party to walk you through make
sure everybody's on the same page where
are we headed what do we want to do here
and how what order we're going to do
that
man you can't go wrong getting everybody
on the same page yeah that's
important and um and i agree with what
you said earlier too that you and sheila
talked about
you do have to put a line on this uh
because otherwise your emotions will
plow past
anything that's reasonable you'll look
up maybe 150 in yeah
or something and i've seen people within
vitro
where they just break the bank yeah they
just keep going back
and that was my wife's wisdom up front
let's draw a line here let's say this is
this is as far as we're going to take
this
and then we're going to work hard but
this is we're not going to cross this
line and i
was that ended up being extraordinary
wisdom as usually
our wives right yes absolutely yeah
there's
it's just it's one of those things it's
very it's it's impossible for people
or yourself to tell yourself no one yeah
it's just a and if you don't you're
going to get in trouble